[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai le grand plaisir la
grande chance d'avoir sur ce plateau un
invité un artiste peintre il est
d'origine ivelino il y a passé quelques
années il s'appelle Olivier de masère
Olivier bonjour bonjour vonique comment
ça va ben ça va très bien je découvre 50
an neline où je viens pas souvent il é
temps parce qu'on est quand même pas
très loin de Versailles voilà ça veut
dire vous avez pas fait vos études à la
faille de Saint-Quentin mais on y
reviendra après sur vos études donc
Olivier de maser bah vous êtes un peu
fébrile là parce que vous préparez une
exposition ah oui c'est ça c'est c'est
c'est installé c'est bon ça va on est tr
alors cet expo on va le dire tout de
suite ça sera fait elle a lieu du 13 au
23 23 décembre décembre voilà hein et
elle est une galerie parisienne qui est
dites-moi tout qui est 9 11 rue de 20
mill c'est dans le c'est dans le 9e 9e
en bas de la place cliché en fait voilà
un chouette quartier un quartier très
sympa oui très vivant en fait assez
jeune maintenant c'est devenu plus jeune
qu'avant oui ça c'est boboisé et moi
j'ai mon atelier à côé place clichiou
derrière la place clich extra alors
c'est même ouvert de 11h du matin à 20h
imaginez-vous c'est un peu les horaires
voilà très bien alors même le dimanche
par contre ça c'est même le dimanche ça
c'est par risen mais on a on a pas
beaucoup de temps oui alors tout ça pour
bah justement à cette occasion moi j'ai
envie de faire mieux connaissance avec
vous je sais quelques petites choses
mais pas tout et je voudrais tout savoir
j'exagère alors donc vous êtes vous avez
passé quelques années à Versailles vous
avez vous êtes arrivé à quel âge écoute
je suis arrivé en 4e donc je 13 ans oui
TR 14 ans à Versailles en venant d'où
alors mon père était préfet donc on se
promenait beaucoup dans mon enfance et
un moment il a été en il a fait une
carrière à Paris dans les ministères et
du coup on s' installle à versaill d'c
et et moi j'ai fait mes études au lycée
Hoche et jusqu'à la prépa à chaussée en
fait prépa à chaussée et après à CHUS et
à chaussée dans la fou encore dans les
ivelines oua foué c'est ça qui
m'interroge qu'est-ce quel était votre
votre
vrai parce que faut quand même beaucoup
travailler pour faire une prépa plus je
après investissement ou mais j'étais un
bon élève en fait et c'était une voix un
peu facile mon frère venait d'y rentrer
mon frère est né et
puis en fait en fait on est on est trois
frères et et c'est drôle je pense à 18
ans c'est très difficile de chois de se
dire moi je veux faire quelque chose
donc la chaus tuit un peu une porte
ouverte plus oui mais j'étais vraiment
pour moi c'était assez facile je suis
rentré à 18 ans à je sais je suent TR
mais à l'époque on est rentr en un an de
prépa c'était je pense c'était moins
lourd qu'aujourd'hui les prépas et tout
ça et puis par contre arrivé à chauss là
je me dis il y a un petit problème je
suis pas sûr que ça m'intéresse le
business ça m'intéressait pas en fait
non la vie ça m'intéressait mais et puis
moi j'ai c'est un truc bête je suis très
claustrophobe je supporte pas d'être
enfermé longtemps dans un bureau la vie
de bureau ça me va pas du tout et à l'p
ah je sais fa beaucoup de sport en fait
c'était super école faire du sport et et
puis l'histoire c'est que mon père est
un peintre amateur ah déjà un peu un
peintre raté c'est cétait vraiment un
sous-préfet qui tous les dimanches
peignait très bien du dimanche d'
l'expression oui mais alors il était
passionné cétait il était plus qu'un
pain du dimanche parce qu'il était
vraiment passionné et assez frustré en
fond de pas en faire plus euh et du coup
c'est vrai que on a beaucoup vé d'expos
jeune on a beaucoup fait même de
galeries pas moi le Louf j'ai découvert
très tard le Louf j'ai découvert assez
âgé jeune on est dans les galeries
beaucoup plus contemporaine et et moi
donc j'avais l'anemour la peinture
depuis l'enfance ça ça m'intéressait
beaucoup mais j'imaginais pas en faire
ma vie en fait c'est ça est-ce que vous
dessinez déjà alors j'ai un truc bizarre
je dessine pas je dis ça en rigol je dis
ça en rigolant mais
mais en fait c'est un truc tout bête
c'est que mon père justement dessinait
très très bien ouais et moi je voulais
faire la peinture et il me passait son à
me dire mais tu sais pas dessiner tu
arriveras pas merci pas très sympa mais
je et en fait j'ai des après qu'on lui
avait dit ça enfant à lui il faisait que
répéter ce qu'on lui avait dit alors que
lui il dessiné magnifiquement et du coup
moi j'ai dit B je faire la peinture
quand même sans dessiner je passais
directement à la peinture et pendant des
années je c'était même bizarre truc de
pas dessiner pas pas aimé dessiner et
puis au beauzard donc j'ai après à
chaussé alors après à chaussé pendant
quelques années j'ai cherchais ma vie
j'ai mes parents m'ont coupé les vivres
j'ai j'ai dû bosser euh pendant bah TR
qu années parce qu'il n'était pas
d'accord que vous ah oui vou surt pas il
sentait que il sentait que j'allais
faire autre chose que la voix normale il
vous sentait sortir du il sentait que le
gars il a pas envie de faire les n comme
les autres voilà et donc c'est pas fait
Lena et euh et puis c'est je me suis mis
à peindre en fait à l'époque on avait
l'armée c'était vachement pratique oui
donc enfin pratique pendant 2 ans je
suis partis un an et demi je suis partis
en Copé euh et là en Copé je suis arrivé
à Stockholm un peu par hasard eu mais
j'aimais l'Europe du Nord je connaissais
un peu l'Europe du Nord et là j'ai peint
en fait j'étais assez seul j'ai commencé
à vraiment peindre j'ai fait trois
explois Stockholm 20 ans c'est
incroyable ça les ses dooigt adorent la
peinture ils ont un très fort rapport à
la peinture public bah c'était en tous
les cas aussi quand quand on est expat
on fait des trucs bizarres qu'on ferait
pas dans son pays facilement voilà et
rentré en France bah j'ai continué un
peu à bosser dans le marketing pour
gagner ma vie mais très vite je voulais
faire autre chose et là j'ai commencé à
AC scè d'opéra que j'avais
rencontré qui j' voulu voulu être son
assistant en me disant que j'allais
faire un métier arti ganpin et la
peinture à côté avec les décors et tout
ça je me suis rendu compte cétait pas du
tout j'étais pas fait pour l'opéra du
tout je pas fait pour le théâtre j'aime
pas être enfermé et en fait au théâtre
on on peut être dans la nuit de 8h du
matin à minuit hein et voilà et puis et
puis lui par contre ce m en scène Pizzi
m'avait parlé de Cremonini qui est un
pain italien un P italien qui est Mor
maintenant qui éit mort maintenant qui
était un peintre très connu dans les
années 80 très il y a beaucoup
d'artistes qui sont passés par alors
voilà et lui est était prof au beauzard
nommé par langue en fait il a eu pas
tant d'élèves que ça on était une
vingtaine mais des gens super motivés il
sélectionnait les g avec beaucoup de
motivation donc moi j'ai été le voir un
peu poussé par Pizzi et vous vous êtes
dit bah il faut que j'ai un diplôme des
Bard que ce soit non pas du tout moi je
voulais apprendre la peinture et ce
bonhomme je trouvais sa peinture géniale
en plus je trouvais sa peinture très gay
je pensais qu'il avait 40 ans moi j'en
avais 20 25 et en fait il en avait 60 sa
peinture était très gay et c'estit un
super pédagogue et lui il m'a fait venir
regarder mon travail il me renvoyer
allez travailler chez vous revenez et au
bout de 6 mois il m'a dit moi je veux
bien prendre comme élève mais rentrer à
l'école moi je voulais plus faire faire
d'école j'éta ah vous aiez une overdose
d'études bah oui d'études ouais et et du
coup je suis rentré au bzard j'ai passé
le concours
d'entrée assez facilement les gars au
concours ils m'ont dit n FHC tirez-vous
vous êtes dingue mais oui vous deviez
être un oven ah ben je crois je un peu
unique même dans l'istoire de chaussé
ouiine et je dis mais non je connais
créonini ah ils ont été le chercher oui
je le prends il travaille beaucoup bon
et suis rentr à l'atelier et j'ai passé
5 ans avec lui quand même donc
finalement pour quelqu'un qui voulait
pas reprendre d'études ou vous avez remp
pour 5 ans j'imagine c'était vraiment
complètement d'autre forme d'étude
c'était mais là est-ce que vous avez dû
ressentir ben là en fait qu chose
d'incroyable en fait il y avait aussi on
était tous passionnés par la peinture
les autres élèves il y avit beaucou
d'étrangers il y avait des Grecs il y
avait des japonais il y avait allemand
américain donc on était une vingtaine
mais très internationale et il avait
sélectionné au fond des gens qui avaient
souvent fait d'autres m
d'autresapentissag oui oui il était pas
ça l'intéressait des gens qui y av il y
avait une femme qui venait de des trucs
médicaux il y avait des musiciens il y
avait des gens qui étaient qui venaient
à la peinture un peu atypiques atypique
mais très très très euh du coup d'autant
plus euh alors voilà et moi r chausé
savait même pas ce que c'était il avait
jamais compris ce que c'était euh bon il
avait compris que c'est des études un
peu business études culturelles voilà il
m'avait mis comme massile l'atelier
c'est celui qui gère un peu les fonds de
l'atelier donc il avait quand même
compris je pouvais un peu faire ça et
puis voilà et c'était et je pense c'est
grâce à lui que j'ai j'ai pu euh bah
j'ai développé un apprentissage
technique assez traditionnel en fait
donc vous avez dessiné là alors un jour
il m'a dit mais pourquoi vous dessinez
jamais je raconter l'histoire de mon
père et c'était très curieux parce que
lui son père aussi était un peintre
amateur et c'était très touchant après
on a eu un autre rapport en fait il a
connu mon père d'ailleurs euh et c'était
très touchant parce que mais a dit mais
c'est con vous savez vous dessinez vous
dessinez très bien mais avec le pinceau
mais voilà c'est ça avec un autre outil
mais votreile on voit qu'il y a du
dessin c'est très dessiné pas de
l'abstrait c'est très dessiné on est
d'accord couleur en fait c'est ça
l'histoire et c'estàd qu'il y a pas
de directement avec la couleur voilà
c'est l'abstraction c'est l'abstraction
du trait noir sur blanc qui est trop
abstrait pour moi en fait quand on
dessine avec la couleur donc moi
j'essine beaucoup avec des pastels c'est
des c'est des c'est déjà des c'est gras
c'est des couleurs et on peut les étaler
on peut les
diluer contour c'est on cherche le
contour avec la couleur tu vois c'est
pas un
contour c'est un contour vient plutô de
l'intériur
parce qu'on n'oublie pas que vous êtes
claustrophobe vous avez pas envie d'être
dans une boite oui c'est ça je ver pas
que c'est pareil et et puis l'autre
chose c'est qu'en fait ça permet d'abord
de dessiner la lumière d'aborder l'ombre
et la lumière qui est très importante de
votre vre et moi c'est ça qui me c'est
ça qui ça que je regarde en fait c'est
ça qui me permet de de dessiner aussi de
comprendre l'espace c'est la lumière et
ça Cremonini c'était son enseignement c
un grand c'est un Italien aussi pour ça
et voilà bon alors maintenant qu'on
connait le début d'où je viens d'où vous
venez voilà donc bah depuis tout ce
tempsl depuis 90 donc vous êtes diplômé
de des beauards voilà et j'ai fait ma
première expo en 90 voilà et depuis
toujours j'ai toujours ma peinture ouais
vous vivez de votre peinture c'est qu
même ass r ouais oui oui c'est c'est une
chance c'est pas toujours très organisé
c'est c'est je me suis aussi souvent
j'ai organisé souvent mes expositions
moi-même j'ai trouvé squatter des lieux
envahir des lieux bizarres j'ai envoyé
des usines j'ai envé des endroits
et aussi en 90 faut dire que faire de la
pint en 90 c'était complètement un
contrecourant c'était un peu excusez-moi
complètement bine on le renvoyer tout le
temp il fallit faire des vidéos il Fall
faire des
installationsing ouis oua c'était
c'était resté dans votre ligne ouais ah
mais moi je j'étais venu j'avais été
élevé dans l'art contemporain en fait et
la peinture me fascinait comme une chose
mystérieuse en fait et et aussi une
chose que en fait c'était une chose
assez simple qui m'intéressait c'était
vraiment je voulais pas me disperser en
fait hm hm en fait peut-être je sais
m'avait fait disperser dans plein de
trucs le droit la conta tout ça qui
m'intéressait pas la pinture ça me
plaisait comme la peinture et donc j'ai
pas voulu sortir oui et puis pour
j'aimais j'aimais vraiment la grande
peinture classique je la je la
connaissais bien finalement et comment
vous définissez aussi si votre style
comment votre peinture benah je fais une
peinture figurative si c'est assez
simple je travail je parle du réel h HM
et c'est là où avec le avec le ré
s'arrête 2 secondes oui qu'est-ce qu'on
voit là à l'écran alors ça c'est un
pastel ça c'est grand ça fait 40 par 60
cm ça c'est des pastels que je fais
dehors dans la rue alors celui-là c'est
au Japon c'est à Kyoto h euh j'ai moi
moi j'ai toujours voyagé pas mal mais
par amitié c'est on m'a emmené quelque
part on m'a invité quelque part oui vous
n'arrivez pas sans connaître personne si
quelqu'un vous invite oui puis surtout
ça ça en fait les peintre souvent on est
assez on a besoin de travailler tout le
temps donc partir voyager pour se
bronzer c'est pas notre truc h h mais
mais là il y a un jeune qui viit à à
Kyoto à Tokyo que j'avais rencontré au
théâtre d'ailleurs par des amis et qui
m'avait dit viens me voir viens me
visiter et moi j'ai toujours aimé la
culture japonaise ça vraiment ça me
fascinait donc je l'ai rejoint là-bas
j'ai passé 3 semaines et là-bas j'ai
rencontré des Japonais extraordinaire
qui sont une famille en fait qui gèent
des très grands temples c'est des c'est
des dignitaires bouddhistes c'est cette
femme qui est vraiment devenue ami son
mari est cardinal en gros et son fils
est évêque c'est on comprend pas comment
ça marche donc le mari dirige c'est
gratin c'est le gratin oui mais c'est le
gratin du de ce monde là quoi et donc
lui le mari dirige un grand temple
impérial à Kyoto et le fils à miajima un
temple sur une île alors l'île le temple
de l'île est magnifique l'île est très
célèbre c'est un espèce de miajima c'est
comme un méga mont sa-michel au Japon
c'est une île de temple très belle ils
m'ont invité là-bas et j'ai exposé
là-bas et du coup vous é en résidence
vous avez pas là-bas en fait alors voilà
ils m'ont dit mais viens viens quand
même 10 jours à miajima travailler parce
que les gens va montrer des gens des
choses miajima je dis c'est bien du coup
on a fait l'exposition à miajima il faut
dire que Miyajima c'est entouré de parc
à vitre et
moi voilà une partie de l'année je vis à
côté de 7 où j'ai un mass ancien où il y
a beaucoup de parc à donc les japonais
ils avaient vu cette histoire de C des
parcs à vit donc j'ai emmené au à
miajima des tableaux sur les parcs à
vitres français et eux ça les fasciné et
enfin ça les intéressait beaucoup oui et
puis j'ai dessiné là-bas pendant une
dizaine de jours et après avait dit moi
j'aimerais passer une semaine à Kyoto
dans le temple impérial d'accord et donc
j'ai eu la chance après pour les
Japonais c'était dingue de vivre là au
ninanji parce que très peu de gens
vivent dans ces temple alors ce tableau
on en a parlé ou pas alors ça c'est ça
c'est le pastel que j'ai fait dans les
rues de Kyoto puisque pendant une
semaine je me suis baladé en fait dans
les rudes que avec votre matériel sous
le bras alors c'est un sac à dos une
centaine de pastels en couleur et et des
cartons qui sont déjà préparés en
couleur alors ça veut dire quoi at
tempura la tempera la tempera c'est
c'est un TR un TR qui se mange ça c'est
japonais la tempera c'est un mot pour
faire joli de la peinture à l'eau c'est
nimporte peinture à comme quand colle et
qu'on dit
qu'on au lieu de coller on maroufle oui
voilà ça maroufle de petit vocabulaire à
vous oui mais c'est surtout les galeries
les gens comme ça après tempéra il a
tempéra à l'œuf il voilà et ça moi je
prépare les fonds avec une peinture
vinylique en fait c'est en fait je prép
pas je fais des grands cartons plein de
tâches je m'amuse à faire plein de
tâches un peu oc et après je les
redécoupe en fonction de ce que je
regarde non en fonction de ce je regarde
je prépare des cartons parce qu'au fond
la peinture à l'huile ne se fait pas sur
du fond blanc c'est c'est c'est elle se
fait sur les fonds colorés pour être
efficace mais alors attendez pardon
parce que là là on est sur le pastel
gras Oui mais le pastel gras c'est comme
de la peinture à l'huile c'est la
peinture à l'huile en bâton alors on
peut donc il faut préparer sa toile donc
vous avez là c'est du carton votre
matériel vos cartons préparés et tu vois
le pastel gras en fait on peut le
délayer avec la terébantine pour faire
des endroits pas crayonnés et on peut
laisser la trace du crayon donc il y a
il y a une double matière il y a le fond
derrière en plus ou moins en couleur et
puis et puis il y a les pastelles dessus
je sais pas s'il y aura d'autres images
de de PEL alors on va voir s'il y a
d'autres images qui arrivent alors ça
c'est alors ça c'est on j'ai montré les
de la suite ça c'est un grand tableau
qui fait plus d' 1,60 qui qui est
d'après ce pastel alors c'est ça donc
vous allez dans le la ville le village
je voyage dans mes voyages l'exposition
c'est exposition sur les villes puisque
dans plusieurs villes de de de mes
voyages il y a quelle ville d'ailleurs
je vous coure alors il y a koto
essentiellement il y a des grands de
Kyoto il y a taragona qui est une ville
sud de la CAT une ville très ancienne on
m' prêté une toit en terrasse pour
regarder la ville d'accord il y a VCI
qui la CAB Georgie que j'ai découvert
cet été avec des amis Georgiens qui est
une ville passionnante très vivante
c'est une V dans la montagne il y a un
million d'habitants qui est à la fois
ancienne moderne c'est un peu la Movida
c'est ah oui c'est une découverte très
gay et puis il y a montm en fait puisque
donc j'ai j'ai un AT
en dessous de mon martre et cette année
il y a 20 ans déjà j'avais travaillé à
dans la rue à Paris puis en fait
travailler dans la ru à Paris c'est pas
si évident hein et j'avais un peu la
trou bah au mond la bêtise alors ça
c'est un tableau de Tarragon justement
ah et là et là c'est 7 là c'est 7 c'est
assez inventé ça c'est voilà c'est mes
vues de Paris que j'ai fait 30 ans c'est
mon martre pareil on m' prêté un balcon
et alors j'ai fait mon barard dans la
rue et mon bar destoit donc ça c'est des
pastels aussi 30 par 40 ok fait au
printemps alors donc vous avez vos
pastels vous rentrez dans votre atelier
et qu'est-ce qui se passe alors non
souvent alors souvent je fais je fais
une série de pastel pendant longtemps là
j'ai fait 15 jours de pastel à Paris
même 3 mois j'ai commencé en mars j'ai
suivi un peu le printemps donc je fais
que des pastels parce que c'est une
espèce de il faut all en fait il faut
aller vite h pour saisir la lumière faut
presque faire ça en une heure donc c'est
une espèce de gymnastique et et ça te
concentre il faut essayer d'en faire
tous les jours en fait et au ils sont de
mieux en mieux au bout de 10 jours de
travail on comprend l'espace et donc
c'est pour ça que je m'installe vraiment
longtemps à taragon je su resta plus une
semaine Kyoto je travais plus d'une
semaine au même endroit Biss pareil je
restais plus une semaine dans les rues
et je voudrais retourner de bici ce
printemps et puis après les tableaux
l'idée des tableaux c'est beaucoup plus
lent c'est c'est j'ai alors qu' soit à
l'huile ils sont à l'huile mais toujours
pareil l'huile sur des fonds à l'eau je
travaille sur des fonds à l'eau je les
élabore à la peinture à l'eau et l'uile
vient comme une espèce de dynamique plus
chromatique plus colorée parler de toi
le plus méditative oui parce que ça je
mets des mois à les faire je mets des
mois vous passez d'une toile à l'autre
oui je fais plusieurs toiles en même
temps donc d'après vos pastels voilà la
plupart du temps c'estelle il m'est
arrivé comme alors dans ma dans autour
autour de moi plein de gens travaillent
d'près photo parce que c'est un outil
pour tout le monde bien sûr moi je
trouve que
le c'est très raide souvent les tableaux
d'après phot ça se voit que c'est fait
d'après phot c'est vrai mais oui parce
qu'en fait le d'abord quand on travaille
directement dehors il y a une part
inconscient ça c'estci on élimine des
choses en fait dans le vrai paysage moi
moi je me suis accroché à la maison
grand l'œil voit l'œil enregistre des
choses la MG des ch pas d'autres et pas
d'autres alors que la photo elle prend
tout la photo elle prend tout pareil
donc c'est ça les peintres qui
travaillent d'après photo souvent après
ils ont un résultat tout est pareil et
ça de c'est très lisible pour moi que
c'est de la photo après je dis pas que
je en même temps que je fais des je
travaille dehors je fais des photos pour
des fois avoir des souvenirs de c'est
quoi ce détail là à quoi ça ressemble
parce que ça c'est quand même un peu
bordélique et si je veux le faire ça
c'est 30 par 40 si je veux le faire le
tableau final il fait plus d'un M70 de
long il a un autre format d'ailleurs
quand on change de de quand quand quand
on change de dimension souvent il faut
changer le format parce que le format
conditionne aussi l'image donc ce qu'on
en petit on VO pas la grandir exactement
pareil ça donne pas du tout le même
résultat là le tableau final il est
beaucoup plus long là vie les plus
longues
d'accord voilà et et mais c'est vrai que
j'aime beaucoup travailler d'après mes
souvenirs il m'arrive de trava il m'est
arrivé de travailler uniquement d'après
des photos mais des conditions très
spéciales par exemple j'e j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur la neige l'exposition
précédente plutôt sur la neige on en
dira juste un mot à la fin parce que là
on se concentre sur le thème en fait de
votre exposition là qui a lieu bah tout
de suite va durer 10 jours voilà après
vous avez un site on peut retrouver
voilà là c'est la neige parce que vous
travaillez aussi alors ça c'était moi
j'aime beaucoup TR en plein air ouais
alors ça c'est une autre technique c'est
vraiment les tableaux qui sont fait
dehors avec la peinture à l'huile sur la
même te carrément mais ça c'est petit ça
fait 40 par 40 donc là j'ai besoin de la
voiture parce qu'en fait mon mon autre
atelier c'est la voiture parce que il
faut en fait quand j'arrive pareil là je
vis en Suisse chez des amis souvent
pendant plus d'une semaine 10 jours et
et j'ai 50 toiles possibles dans la
voiture c'est des petites toiles avec
des formats différents je me balade je
cherche cher l'endroit je sors l'étoile
de la voiture laquelle je prends par
rapport au fond coloré par rapport au
format et là il y a une boîte chevalier
c'est super lourd tu vois il y a du Maal
c'est lourd donc il faut quand même
avoir la voiture je comprends j'avais vu
une exposition de mon qui m'avait
j'avais lu un truc c'est parce que Mony
il travaille beaucoup dehors aussi mais
pas très un peu plus grand pas mal
dépinre des ivelines du 19e voilà et
comment il faisait parce que des fois il
est perdu au bord d'une rivière dans la
Creuse et en fait il y avait une lettre
de lui très drôle qui expliquait qu'il
arrivait quelque part et trouvait un
jeunne costaud
mat mais oui c'est ça donc un gars qui
lui porte ses boîes de chevalet trois
quatre châssis pour se baler dans la
montagne parce que c'est vrai que alors
ça cette technique de travail dehors
avec la voiture c'est c'est un
trucé on doit avoir un petit peu froid
au bout un moment ah ça c'était
l'horreur parce que combien de temps on
met pour faire un tableau comme ça après
vous pouvez le reprendre chez vous peu
plus ces petites choses je les reprends
pas pas fait pour non il faut saisir le
truc mais en gros je tiens une heure
mais monnaye je sais pas com fa alors
Mony il revenait sans doute plusieurs
jours deus suite oui il faut aller vite
c'est ça qui est drôle dans cette dans
dans ma pratique c'est que je il y a des
moments où je de aller très vite c'est
avec un matériau qui est pas fait pour
finalement luuile c'est pas spécialement
pour aller vite si bah on peut faire des
notes à l'huile très vite oui mais selon
moi c'est un matériau sur lequel on
revient et alors voilà c'est l'autre
version de l'huile mais on peut faire
les deux d' ok non non l'huile l'huile
après en vrai c'est quand même une
question de métier c'estd ça travailler
dehors à l'huile en 1 heure réussir des
trucs j''y arrivais pas à 30 ans c'est
c'est 30 ans MTI évolution ouis vous
disiez plusis on travaille et et puis on
est bon ouais et alors dites-moi C thème
moi je trouve que enfin c'est peut-être
pas terriblement dit mais je le dis
quand mêmeos vos thèmes qu'on voit dans
dans ces tableaux de ville ce ce parking
ce parking à 7 ces immeubles c'est on a
l'impression que vous vous arrivez
devant un lieu euh il y a il y a un
camion il on voit un rétroviseur dans un
coin d'une toile ça vous alors moi je me
dirais bon c'est pas très très Jojo quoi
et en fait vous en faites quelque chose
de beau vous sortez de ce ce trivial de
ce quotidien hyper concret pour en en
faire une œuvre qui finalement bah ça
gêne plus quand on voit ça ça fait
partie du tableau de la lumière des
couleurs comprenez ce que vous êtes
attiré par complètement mais c'est aussi
c'est aussi parce que peindre par
exemple C c'est une ville très
photographiée très peinte il y a des
coins ravissants si
je Venise ça alors que
là c'est un peu petit peu inventé parce
que quand je travaille en grand là c'est
un c'est un parking sauvage à 7 qui
était qui est devenu un vrai parking
maintenant à l'entrée de la ville où on
se garait n'importe comment la nuit et
moi je trouvais cet endroit il y avait
des lampadaires il y avait c'était
incroyable le fil c'était un peu GL ça
faisait un peu peur quand même c'est
vrai ou il était quelle heure ah là
alors ça c'est un tableau qui est très
grand et donc ça je l'ai fait l'atelier
sur plusieurs mois mais j'ai travaillé
dehors sur des pastels je me rappelle je
je me garais la nuit et puis les
voitures tout coup arrivai me voyent par
terre c'est qui ce gars il av peur en
fait il des moment pe tout av pe non
mais les gens qui se gar moi j'ai pas
peur moi j'avais pas peur non mais les
gens qui se g prtique c'était pas un
lieu pour alors à l'époque pas trop mais
c'était il y a quelques c'était pardon
non puis c'était un peu c'était saison
c'était c'était plus en période
touristique en octobre avant qu'il fasse
froid et moi c à minuit je travaille
dehors à minuit et et c'est pas j'en ai
fait plusieurs grands tableaux après je
réinventre par exemple l'espèce de rue
qui s' s'enfonce comme ça elle n'existe
pas dans la vraie vie c'est des hangars
et et quand on travaille sur les tche au
bout d'un moment on voit des choses et
et on invente des espaces aussi mais oui
mais moi elles me plaisent beaucoup ces
voitures c'est les voiture d'abord moi
c'est con j'adore rouler parce que c'est
c'est comme ça que je voyage pour
visiter avec mon matériel et ensuite
c'est des pièges à lumière quoi c'est
des pièges à couleur c'est moi je trouve
ça oui ça cette trivialité ça m'attire
oui ça c'est vrai de de de de la
regarder telle qu'elle est quoi et je on
peut la trouver très belle mais voilà
voilà on peut la trouver par vos yeux
oui mais moi j'inviterai les gens à la
trouver belle aussi oui je comprends ça
c'est un peu une invitation à trouver
beau ce qui est autour de nous voilà
c'est plutôt ça mon idée plutôt que de
trouver mieux à travers votre peinture
quand même on ferit une petite photo bê
du parking je suis pas sû
ah oh là là avec une histoire de pompe à
essence la nuit un film américain c'est
au secours euh per connu euh bon c'est
pas grave tant pis il y a surtout un
peintre hyper connu au pèreou voilà au
père depuis que j'expose même j'avais
fait une exposion Berlin en 2000 je
crois 2001 je me rappelle plus et les
Allemands ils ont pas tellement
l'habitude de voir une peinture assez
figurative comme ça et tout de suite il
m'avait dit ah ça fait penser à au peur
et on me l'a souvent dit parce qu'en
effet j'ai pas de station service j'ai
pas des bord route pas de il y a pas de
personnage alors si moi j'ai des petits
Mo j'ai beaucoup il y a des petits
personnag est plus il est plus sur des
des scènes de personnages et moi je mets
de plus en plus des gens dans les
tableaux dans cette exposition il a il y
a des petits personnages dans tous les
tableau silhouettes quand même des
silhouettes dans la rue des mais je suis
pas quelqu'un en fait j'aime beaucoup
faire des vrais portrait c'est l' ou
l'autre voilà soit vous faites ça je
fais des portraits je fais poser les
gens fais des vrais portrait que j'aime
beaucoup faire c'est vrai vous avez des
commandes alors j'en ai pas énormément
parce que c'est plus ça se fait plus
tellement finalement
alors moi des fois je demande à des amis
de poser pour moi en gros il faut quand
même poser quatre séances d'une de 2h C
fa de 8 et les gens c'est pas si long
mais mais ça fait des portraits c'est
dommage j'ai pas amené des portraits qui
sont très figuratifs moi j'aime beaucoup
portraits et vous faites Jama d'exos de
portrait alors je l'ai fait une fois et
ben la prochaine fois vous reviendrez
pour une expo de portrait d'accord on n
après il faut que je les arrache aux
gens parce qu'ils sont plus chez moi les
mais c'est pasre problème mon cher
Olivier d'accord bon on se quitte sur ce
magnifique paysage de neige ouais Suisse
c'est la vallé de gruyère c'est un
endroit très beau c'est c'est un endroit
que j'aime énormément très tendre très
paysant en fait c'est la Suisse que les
gens connaissent pas c'est enfin c'est
pas la Suisse luxe quoi oui la Suiss
ruraleès touchante très gens très gentil
bon je crois que le temps qui
mercivol un grand merci plein de succès
pour votre belle exposition donc du 13
au 23 décembre et puis après on peut
aller voir sur votre site Rud 2000 dans
le 9e le thème différentes villes que
vous avez parcouru à travers le monde
mon Instagram aussi à mon et votre
Instagram à votre nom Olivier deasière
voilà merci Olivier et bravo pour ce
magnifique travail qui nous fait
rêver à bientôt merci de nous avoir
suivi à très
vite
[Musique]